I'm will Kane in for Laura Ingram on
this special edition of the Ingram angle
from New York City tonight I want to
wish a very big congratulations to the
bite administration because they have
hit a brand new record
we did it we did it Joe
you're gonna be the next president of
the United States
they did it we just learned that last
month they had the highest number of
illegal immigrant apprehensions at the
border ever for the month of August and
so far in this fiscal year there's been
nearly 233
000 apprehensions already beating out
last year that's basically importing a
Boise Idaho a Spokane Washington a
Scottsdale Arizona every month so that's
Joe Biden's closed border it's so locked
down that we needed to go now live to
Eagle Pass Texas where Fox News National
correspondent Chris Jenkins is there to
show us exactly how tight this closed
border is by the bite Administration
Griff
hey Will good evening happy Friday to
you and it just doesn't stop the numbers
keep coming and coming here in Eagle
Pass you walk along the riverbank will
and you see that this is a crisis Texas
putting the miles of this dense
dangerous barbed wire razor wire which
isn't stopping the migrants from coming
through in fact let's go to our drone in
the sky right now and you can see it's
getting hotter in the afternoon the
groups have been smaller the last few
hours but we see still just a couple of
migrants the back part of a larger group
that came earlier they're still
struggling to negotiate that razor wire
trying to get through why because they
know that this Administration favors
Mass Catch and Release and they are
likely to be guaranteed the ability to
stay get a notice to appear at a court
date years from now that they won't show
up to and now in the case of Venezuelans
many will be able to get a work
authorization and get work which is the
reason why they left their countries to
begin with but economic insecurity isn't
enough to to qualify for Asylum under
our laws yet this Administration has
created an incentive to get them here
and you talk about the 232 000 a month
of August it's just in a long stream of
this year fiscal year we now know CBP
sources confirming to us will that there
is nearly 2.4 million migrant encounters
the most ever on record breaking last
year's all-time high record of
2.378 million and it's just not stopping
with 2400 in the last 24 hours here now
let me show you some of the video that
we've been shooting all day today and
yesterday of the migrants going through
that razor wire but not all of them make
it will in fact just a few hours ago
they pulled yet another body from the
river just feed from where we're
standing it's the third drowning in as
many days three drownings in three days
that is why these agents are having to
see this and they're reaching a Breaking
Point will they're overworked they're
overwhelmed they don't see support from
an Administration Nation they don't see
policy changes coming and yet the
numbers keep rising and rising and now
they're having to pull bodies out of
this River or treat wounded migrants
coming through the razor wire now here
in Maverick County the Sheriff Tom
schwerber that is in Maverick County
where Eagle Pass is a part of I asked
him can you sustain this can this
continue here's what he had to say take
a listen can Maverick County sustain
these numbers no no way no way as you
can see uh
these people here walking and they're
not running away from anybody because
they know they're they're not going to
be stopped by anybody
and here in Eagle Pass that's a
situation but other sectors are getting
hammered as well well in El Paso they're
seeing the same surge in numbers in
three cases they've had in the last 24
hours confirmed cases of tuberculosis
highly contagious disease and it is hard
to overstate how difficult it is for
border patrol agents to mitigate having
overwhelmed numbers and your shelters
are over capacity so you have nowhere to
put them and now you have to contact
Trace among two three four thousand
people a day with tuberculosis running
through it it's absolutely a crisis and
every sense of it in in a sign of it
slowing down live images right there
Griff you're giving us of people trying
to make their way through that razor
wire into the United States thank you so
much Griff hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else